has anyone noticed this yeah by the way
I I'm just pointing it out now in case
you haven't now of course like there's
gonna be two whole pages of comments
they won't the smell with this now I'm
gonna be a good day if I notice it so
then now you'll notice say if you
haven't um okay so this is no one can
hear you is that excuse me um okay can
we get a happy episode again good god
it's like the past three were directed
by Clint Eastwood or something like yeah
everything's dying it's depressing and
yeah oh come on the last one had a
heavier I think I mean we don't know we
don't know what he saved everyone okay
like they all have happy endings but
it's like dude okay so we got I really
thought this one was like a dream I
didn't think it was really going on you
got this you got this D here that comes
in is just like licking people which you
don't think is that bad and then Finn
and Jake trying to stop him uh okay not
as bad as it's going to be as we find
out it's like he looks at prisons like
you know that's annoying n-not oh my god
I can't leave it scrapping just saying
lick him now yeah it's not that annoying
it's just a little bit bad no because
it's a little bit annoying did you miss
the keyword annoy no don't look at that
great time for that later so Finn gets
his legs old you know Voyager's and
stuff and gets none and he wakes up he
thinks like a day later turns out it's
months later and Jake got hit on his
head and he goes a little crazy which
makes me wonder like how where is his
brain in there well what is there to
injure cuz he could change anything I
was going on during that but so he's
going crazy and it's just sort of them
living with their craziness it kind of
like a Waiting for Godot set up kind of
and eventually Finn goes down into the
sewer finds all the people are stuck to
these walls and it brings
and stuff because the deer it turns out
is an evil licking deer because his
licking can stick people to walls are
like stickers and he takes off his
hooves and their hands and like nothing
else I I think that's my favorite joke
cuz I am waiting for him to take the
hose off and then the antlers and then
unzips it but notjust the hooves
nothing is hugely funny oh and even just
the way he does the hands just I mean
it's like the knife and claws are we're
just normal that was my favorite part
okay so uh so he knocks out Jake again
he gets back to normal and they save the
day and that's I mean that's it but good
got like this one made me feel like
uncomfortable watching it I mean I think
in a good way I mean I think that was
the intention but I just felt like just
really uncomfortable I'll think about it
how many jokes were actually in this
episode when you get down to it it was a
very joke free it was a couple but it's
more like how creepy can
Jake get it's a what is up with Naruto
okay he is like a total camera whore now
look why are you such a camera whore cuz
I can be it can't be come on scratch me
he's a total scratcher yeah they're good
that's why I keep Tom at the episode
this will entertain while you can really
talk leave our leaf that cantaloupe
leave the cat alone leave the guy he
wants to play stay the hell waiting for
his birthday party okay I never know it
gets like what are you doing oh it's
just gonna be like mystery kitty theater
night you see the big fun of myself on
it but yeah you were saying someone's
lost his mind - no I mean look at how
many jokes were actually in this and
even the jokes weren't on the whole like
haha that's funny it's more on the
that's really bizarre that's really
strange yeah like is it disturbing and
uncomfortable
well like him just laying there and like
you see it like a bug just come out of
his ear and you're like ha ha I think
it's like do I laugh or what about how
do i exactly go out about this when he
has his puppets you know so yeah ha ha
wow that's actually really kind of
disturbing and creepy good um a lot of
good atmosphere
oh yeah we trans just when he wakes up
and nobody's around and president echo
even yeah the echo nobody's there is
very wet 20 days later yeah yeah remind
me a lot of that and what the candy
people stuck to the wall reminded me
immediately yeah very alien without a
doubt and and yeah like that was creepy
and kind of unsettling is I really
thought it was like he got knocked down
this was all gonna be like his dream or
something like that it's just like no
they can't go this dump again this
unsettling job and it's yeah Jake for
the first time is actually pretty creepy
it's the percentage he made of like
legitimately like I'm kind of afraid of
you Jake he lost his freaking mind
yeah I still love though and then gets
his legs broken like twice crack crack
he's like that and then of course at the
end there's Jake are you fine yeah I'm
fine how about you legs are still broken
like yeah whatever like just so broken I
think the only thing that it's got like
a weird nitpick but uh nitpick I know
imagine uh when they save everybody at
the end it's like whatever the whole
Candy Kingdom is was it like five people
that were hanging on it the up there was
a little weird and I mean what if he
find it was like the entire cake give us
out how they were all like a god or
something like that would be great and
then like I didn't know about that sugar
lined either was that oh the wall was
principal go hey yeah Jen you wanted our
sugar but I wouldn't give him any if you
know what I mean well then look at
Vinnie he's just kind of like like he
doesn't even know how to answer let's go
now
I get a feeling I like somebody that's
almost like a
they're like they're writing and they're
just like somebody said that line is
like no I dare you naturally put that
but should I say we get that past the
censors and they did I really shocked a
lot of this oh well watching you pass
this sense I'm even the breaking those
legs oh yeah rusev well while we're
watching Jory sitting there when the
deer licks himself like oh the deer just
kind of looks and licks himself and then
goes off and joints like oh my god
yeah it's like the legs broken are okay
the people stuck to walls guy yeah look
at all creepy people getting eaten alive
and the couple before that was okay but
a deer liked him so I said sir do your
job I was saying I think as long as they
don't show what he's licking and I don't
like you can get away he would think
it's it's weird censorship is so wide um
but I it was good it was a good episode
attention personally one of my favorites
just because it's so it's so atmospheric
and so atmospheric and so like none joke
how do you like there's so few jokes
throughout this whole thing
and instead of relying on the jokes it
relied more on just the bizarreness of
the situation yeah and I like how long
yeah I like how it would Jake there's
almost this strange tragedy to Jake
that's one and you feel legitimately bad
now of course we gets his head knocked
baggies like oh I'm fine whatever and
I'm sure you'll forget about it but it's
like yeah it's just you just feel bad
that just for months he's been doing
this and he's just chasing this dream
that'll never come you know I need to
loot it himself and it's just it's
really Sally and might be a lot of
Waiting for Godot just these two crazy
people waiting for something that'll
probably never come and it's just like
yeah there's just I was just like wow
there's like something kind of deep here
almost but it's like it's so crazy and
insane it's hard to put more words to
that so yeah weird
chica be in the next one cuz I'm tired
of looking over there
she should be you got me in the next one
maybe you and your natural defences next
one jewelry and or cat or both neither
should be the next one whether she likes
her not by